hey guys it is the 18th of sep tember my
name is Jess McDonald and you are tuned
in to gamespot news TGS has officially
kicked up in Japan and although you and
I can't be there we can't watch all the
cool trailers and get all the sweet news
so let's do that there are way too many
awesome things to mention them all right
now but one that is worth bringing up is
the brand new Final Fantasy 15 trailer
the trailer which touts itself as a
sneak peek kicks off with four heroes
piled into a convertible checking out a
super big monster on the side of the
road so far it seems like the combat is
going to play out in real time if the
trail is anything to go by and they're
also appear to be caught and day/night
cycle inclusions series veteran Tetsuya
Nomura has elected to step away from the
project to focus on Kingdom Hearts 3 you
can check out the beautiful road trip
heavy trailer for yourself on site if
you prefer to cast your attention to new
IP then you'll be glad to hear that
action RPG blood-borne got itself a
Western release date and a brand new
trailer we have a vague idea of when
from software's newest grim creation
would fall into our laps but now we know
for sure that the game will land on ps4
exclusively on februari 6 in North
America and Europe a collector's edition
of the game has also been revealed which
includes a steelbook game case an art
book and a digital soundtrack that one
will run you just under 80 bucks as for
the awesome trailer you've been watching
the doom and gloom is clearly out in
full force and this one also seems to
have dragon monsters I guess dragons are
in this year finally take to come out to
say why they think there's still a
market for GTA 5 on u consoles even
though they've already shifted 34
million units take-two interactive
president carlotta has said that the
xbox one and ps4 versions of the open
world action game could sell hardware to
people who haven't yet jumped on the GTA
5 train as for those who may have
already bought the game slat upstairs
the new versions of the something
special from both a graphics and content
perspective as far as we know this
content includes over 100 new radio
station songs as well as exclusive
vehicles and weapons take two of also
said they think they're in a good
position to continue making money off
GTA online given that people can spend
real world money for virtual items
answer your question of the day let me
know if you think many people are going
to be picking up GTA 5 for xbox one or
ps4 and if you're one of them or not
that is it for me today be sure to head
to gaze what to check out all the good
things that have been coming out of TGS
and join me same time tomorrow for the
top five stories of the whole gaming
wink I will free them